we get to this third density this human
density now this is very
highly sought after obviously
because you become self-aware you become
aware
that you're aware you become aware
that you have choice that you have will
that when you're exposed to the choice
of do i serve myself or do i
serve other people which we'll talk
about as
sts service to self versus
sto service to others
you have will you have choice you have
polarity
right so self-awareness and polarity
this is typically what's also called the
third
density or 3d matrix
so when people talk about the matrix
they're
referencing something of course that's
also used in
mathematics but they're talking about it
in a sense of
the government in terms of the economic
machinery in terms of
politicians in terms of propaganda in
terms of all the main
media companies in terms of all of the
fast food and high fructose corn syrup
and all
of the endarkenment and asleepening
mechanisms that keep people
like algorithmic sheep
than liberated
sovereign gnostic
beings that know their true infinite
nature
and that's really what is core here
when you go from the third to the fourth
density
is it's typically the what is called
in many ways the first stage of
enlightenment
which is when you recognize that i am
not
a contracted finite
separate energy egoic
i'm not that and you sort of
relax and expand yourself into a more
cosmic consciousness
you begin recognizing a little bit more
subtly that
okay well we all come from the same
source
we all come from that same big bang
and our awareness then
is also shared like our sources
and i become more subtly aware
of awareness itself
and i recognize that the observer the
witness
is paramount it's salient
it's critical
just like i reference in
my dream at night that i have i
can't actually simulate out that dream
and have that experience without
an observer without a witness without
awareness so there is awareness
simulated and the reality
for awareness to experience
so look at your direct experience at
night when you simulate out the dreams
and recognize
the poignancy the paramountness
of the observer of the witness
of awareness itself and then take that
here
away from that dream into
your awake state
and recognize that same paramountness
okay so you are
the creator
and you are the awareness
and you are the unique firework
that is your unique gift and expression
that's why the first part is called
nettie nettie not this not that you
negate
being this costume you negate being even
awareness
so that you can recognize yourself as
the creator you can
recognize pierce the veilus veil the
gateless gate
to that as your true nature and then
step one is that nerineti step
two is the inclusion so in step two you
include
yourself as the creator as the
impersonal
eternal awareness and as
the unique cool firework gift
costume
so the ascension from third to fourth
includes that moving away from person
into moving more and more towards
the cosmic consciousness and
it is really critical here
you move away from service to self
dynamics where you want to self deal
to yourself you're trying to extract
peace and happiness
from maya from the illusion from
substances and experiences and other
people
to now you recognize that your
nature is happiness and peace
awareness is nature is that the
creator's nature is that
so you no longer try and extract it from
maya rather
you become in service because you
recognize the quote
other is actually the self is the
creator
so that way you become in service to
others or
s-t-o instead of s-t-s
so that's really the core
of where we're at right now
so cosmically speaking
we are
so again this was do re
me we're in the me to fa
and in that me to fa we have to remember
that there's a polarity there there's no
sharp
and so the polarity is the service the
self versus the service to other
and so the quote
3.5 is where a lot of people are
currently feeling
right now
our role as people that care a lot about
service to others that care a lot about
love
awakening to the fourth density of love
which
again these are the chakras as well
that this fourth chakra is the heart
chakra and when you open the heart
chakra
that's when you get love you get cosmic
consciousness you get the
recognition that we share our being
which is what the definition of love is
so this is so mission critical when we
talk about things like global
enlightenment or when we talk about the
planetary awakening
we're talking about shifting people from
human third density service to self
to fourth density love service to
others expanding them from
person to more of a
shepherding of consciousness